hey did you vote
yeah was this your first time going to
your 20 so it had to be your first time
yeah first time
like i just had an argument with someone
yesterday about how important it is to
vote and
uh you know i think that's dope that you
voted
let's leave that sweater show everybody
that sweater black voters matter man
it's true
a little bit higher there he is
uh it's no no
no no but but it's crazy because that
sweater is the realest [ __ ] ever because
right now the reason why donald trump's
not about to be president
is literally because of black voters
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] him real [ __ ] [ __ ] him he could
suck my dick like real talk
like he look like a piece of baloney he
doesn't
yes he does for real like i was looking
at him he looked like baloney with here
yeah he looks like [ __ ] [ __ ] is crazy i
just saw he said they said they seen
you seen the poster where he said he was
jacking off ghosts oh where he's like
this
safe to say you're not doing the little
pump feature huh yeah
i ain't never even liked that [ __ ]
that's fair like real talk i don't
i don't even know why [ __ ] made him
famous like and i i don't really care
about rappers
real [ __ ] but like if he see this and he
like try to get some clout
i'm gonna let you know bro like i really
beat the [ __ ] out you like
everything i love i believe that like
real [ __ ] i really beat the [ __ ] up with
him like
i don't even believe that i don't even
play like this i think little pump
is um an a product of
the worst era in hip-hop history and
they're gonna and i'm gonna tell you
something they're gonna try to get i
know they're gonna try to get club for
me
let me tell you something right rap
[ __ ] is gonna try me
and i'm gonna let y'all know right now
like i i'm not going back and forth on
the internet with y'all
i'm not gonna respond to y'all i'm gonna
get up with y'all
a little bit later that's what i'm going
to tell y'all so like well i appreciate
what you've done
and that is not blow up because you're a
spectacle on the internet you've
blown up through hard work through
cataloging putting out music to building
your fan base organically
and i think little pump is quite the
opposite he blew up
from being a spectacle yeah like it was
more about
six nine is the same people if you ask
me certainly
this is the same people what's worse
being a snitch
or being a outspoken trumper in hip-hop
which one's worse man honestly i could
say
oh my god that's hard it's hard right
like i mean it's running around with the
mag like being a trumper
or being a snitch like that [ __ ] damn
their equivalent
like if you that shit's equivalent
i think it's close right i said it's
equivalent to snitching
so if you're yeah i think i think so
anybody out there
if you and i don't give a [ __ ] who like
what you did is what you did
yeah you feel what i'm saying but if you
did
if you did go for him honestly
you know what i say man that's what i
said [ __ ] over yeah i mean but [ __ ] you
for right now that's what i say
it's the difference between people who
voted for trump
and who ride around with the flags and
the hats sex
right there's [ __ ] they're i
call them cult members
but you know what though a lot of peop
you got
a lot of people who didn't vote for
biden
because of the tax increase
that's what i'm saying dumb [ __ ] this
the camera right here yeah
you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] the tax increase
was for people that was making 400 000
or more
or more [ __ ] you ain't making that much
money getting broke
and you were talking about are you
worried about a [ __ ] tax increase
you was never you just ordered off the
dollar menu at taco bell
not even that like yo [ __ ] all right
he was gonna be president for like four
years probably not another president
come around and
you know we don't know how that's right
right right right in four years [ __ ]
you wasn't gonna be rich
i'ma just be honest i you [ __ ] lazy
you've been broke you're gonna stay
broke ain't [ __ ] about you gonna change
you might as well both vote for biden
and not
and and and and and this is what i tell
people look
talking about a [ __ ] tax increase
[ __ ] you broke first of all the tax
increase thing is a very unrealistic
thing that's gonna get passed
yeah it's still gotta go through get
this orange [ __ ] to [ __ ] up out
of here and worry about everything later
yeah let's try to save the country yo
people used to people used to
yo i hear people talking about yeah man
people used to love donald trump he used
to be i ain't man
like i'm the [ __ ] if that [ __ ] like was
on wrestling and all that other [ __ ]
[ __ ]